[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric sinclair éditorialiste qui est
en direct avec nous parce qu'avec vous
avez été l'un des conseillers politiques
de dominique de villepin quand il était
premier ministre bonsoir frédéric saint
clair merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau en studio alexis poulain qu'on
connaît très bien ici notre
éditorialiste bonsoir alexis xavier
bertrand dont valérie pécresse philippe
juvin michèle bernier ou encore david
lisnard ça fait du monde déjà à droite
les candidats sortent du bois c'est une
vraie purée de pois ce qui inquiète
évidemment les ténors du parti comme
notamment le sénateur a l'air de vendée
bruno retailleau avant de vous faire
réagir messieurs je vous propose de
l'écouter
le meilleur ennemi de la droite c'est la
droite ce sont nos confusion nos
divisions nos confusion qui trop souvent
des routes nos électeurs nous divisions
qui les dégoûte non il faut que on
arrive à se situer et à nous hisser à
hauteur de cet enjeu en portant un vrai
projet et ce projet là ça ne peut pas
être une droite de contrition qui le
porte ça doit être une droite de
conviction est celui qui a donc surpris
tout le monde c'est laurent wauquiez on
en parlera tout à l'heure clairement le
meilleur ennemi de la droite c'est la
droite raid eric sinclair vous confirmez
historiquement oui c'est vrai
il ya une ya un ferment de
division si on regarde un tout petit peu
plus près en réalité il ya un non dit à
droite
la droite quand on revient aux années 80
c'était le rpr et l'udf
qui faisait alliance au moment des
échéances électorales et dans une
alliance on passe un contrat qu'on est
libre de respecter ou pas mais si on ne
respecte pas en rond et à ce moment là
chacun reprend ses billes il ya une
espèce de d'honnêteté intellectuelle à
dire bon bah on va essayer de travailler
ensemble et on va voir mesure on peut le
faire quand on a fabriqué l'ump cette
espèce d'énorme
machine à gagner l'élection
présidentielle
ça a été bénéfique quand il ya eu une
personnalité qui a été capable à la fois
de séduire rpr et udf mais quand il n'a
plus été le cas c'était une machine à
perdre et on est là aujourd'hui on est
dans une machine et l'eire qui me
ressemble plus à rien parce qu elle qu
alice des courants qui ne regardent plus
dans la même direction il cessa en
réalité qui le le vrai nom dit tout le
monde rêve encore d'un grand ump mais la
vérité c'est que ce dont il a besoin à
droite c'est d'un menu des f1 nouveau
udf et nous et repères ça y est alexis
poulain la machine à perdre comme on
l'appelle tous les jours au roi c'est
devenu voilà un mot du larousse aussi
jose dur elle est lancée cette machine à
perdre parce que c'est vrai que quand on
est partisan de ce parti ça fait un
petit peu peur ben oui le problème de la
primaire que ce soit à gauche comme à
droite c'est que ces grands partis ont
sont allés un peu vite dans un système à
l'américaine pensant que les
institutions françaises la vie politique
française pouvait
s'adapter il n'en est rien on voit bien
que la question de la gestion du débat
la question d'émotion que ce soit parti
socialiste mais des courants aussi on
parlait de l'udf ou du rpr pour mettre
tous ces gens autour d'une table ça
prend beaucoup de temps et il faut
surtout éviter les caméras or une
primaire c'est un exercice de
communication de marketing politique qui
fait beaucoup de mal puisque on dit
beaucoup de choses l'idée c'est de se
démarquer d'arrivée être celui qui va
être élu et une fois les choses fait le
pire c'est qu'on a des personnalités
comme manuel valls qui s'engagent sur
parole à soutenir le candidat et qui une
fois le candidat et vu que c'est pas lui
dire vous savez je reprends ma liberté
donc ça ne peut pas fonctionner dans un
cadre où il n'ya pas de règle et où il
n'y a pas une habitude ça marche quand
on a deux les grands rôles partys des
partis américains qui ont cette capacité
à faire le débat en interne et qui
comprennent qu'un seul candidat peut
marcher dans ce système dit partisan en
france c'est vraiment tout autre chose
et je crois que la réflexion est en
train d'être fait en direct c'est un peu
tard pour ses parties de se dire est ce
qu'on va le faire l'erreur des primaires
où est ce qu'on va trouver une autre
façon de faire
mais aujourd'hui la question est posée
et on voit bien que personne ne souhaite
être les premiers à y répondre parce
qu'en même temps les primaires ça permet
pas de reflux renflouer les parties
puisqu'il faut payer pour y participer
et ça permet aussi de prendre un peu de
temps médiatique et c'est ce que je vais
vous dire pendant que vous êtes bien
pessimiste messieurs parce que on se
souvient que les primaires de la droite
en 2016 à frédéric 5 heures je parle
sous votre contrôle c'était quand même
plutôt un succès plus de 4 millions de
votants les finances des partis remise à
plat candidats propulsèrent aux sorties
des primaires on ne racontera pas la
suite évidemment pour lui avec 66 %
d'intentions de vote qu'est ce qui
coince cette fois ci
ce qui compte c'est que les une grande
partie du personnel politique de droite
crois que c'est la primaire de 2016 qui
a fait l'échec de 2017 or en réalité il
n'ya que françois fillon qui portent
cette responsabilité
quand jeudi françois fillon
bien comprendre qu' il n'était pas tout
seul à porter la responsabilité il ya le
pnf qui a été père a pu enfin on connaît
l'histoire j'ai pas vouloir faire il ya
eu une dénonciation il ya tout un tas de
trucs et le robert bourgi qui est venu
faire le clown à l'antenne donc il ya
voilà il ya eu toute une tout a tout eu
tout un cadre qui acquit qui s'est
effondré sous les pieds de la droite et
puis des défections valérie pécresse
xavier bertrand christian estrosi ont
été les premiers à planter des couteaux
dans le dos de françois fillon dont les
premiers à déserter d'ailleurs de l'e3
on quittait le parti aujourd'hui donc
fondamentalement c'est ça qui a qui a
qui a effondrée la droite or on la tribu
en réalité à la primaire qui vous l'avez
dit et c'était assez justes a été un
grand moment de télévision et finalement
quelque chose de plutôt positif parce
qu'on a vu émerger une figure françois
fillon qu'on attendait pas du tout au
début on pensait que juppé serait
vainqueur en réalité nicolas sarkozy
était sur le retour et puis il a pas pu
concourir au deuxième tour donc
fondamentalement c'était plutôt une
bonne surprise il aurait pu arriver dans
cette primaire là avec la même espérance
et se dire bon on va faire quelque chose
d'un peu punch et on va occuper l'espace
médiatique pendant tout l'automne c'est
pas du tout le cas il joue petit bras et
en jouant petit bras avec des primaires
comme ça ça coûte cher et on se plante
oui on se plante est en tout cas
certains ne veulent même pas se mouiller
et laurent et il a surpris tout le monde
je le disais tout à l'heure l'ancien
président des républicains actuel patron
de la région rhône-alpes a renoncé à sa
candidature je vous propose justement
d'écouter ses raisons
aucun candidat ne s'impose à droite et
personne n'a la force et la légitimité
pour imposer sa candidature comme de
gaulle pompidou où sarkozy ont pu le
faire je vois les candidatures à droite
se multiplier dangereusement sans même
que l'on sache comment elles seront
départagées et je vois les dangers que
font peser les aventures solitaires sur
nos chances de victoire
alexis poulain à xavier bertrand qui
refuse pas de passer par la case
primaire bah évidemment mais mais encore
une fois on a affaire à des candidats
qui ne sont pas membres pas encarté au
parti qui va organiser les primaires
donc ces primaires de la droite et du
centre elles sont déjà à handicap en
réalité un parti peut faire des
primaires avec des gens qui sont au sein
du parti il faut d'abord un intérêt
commun il faut des idées communes une
plate forme programmatique à la base or
là on voit bien que c'est une affaire
d'ego c'est une affaire de marketing
politique il suffit d'écouter valérie
pécresse qui à longueur de plateau
explique qu'elle est là pour les
nouvelles idées le renouveau et qui fait
finalement dû reçu cette idée de
françois fillon et d'autres depuis des
années vous aviez bertrand qu'il essaye
de jouer la carte à la hollande du du
candidat normal le français moyen qui va
essayer de réconcilier ce pays mais
pareil on attend de voir quelle va être
quelque part dans son programme donc on
est vraiment dans dans un exercice de
communication politique qui dessert le
jeu des idées du débat politique qui
demande plus de temps qui demandent plus
d'implication aussi qui demande plus de
travail de la part des militants mais
aussi de ces personnes qui vont ensuite
incarné ses idées donc on a l'impression
que c'est un peu le le prêt-à-penser il
faut aller vite et puis il faut dire
vous savez l'idée c'est d'être face à
emmanuel macron donc je vais essayer
d'être tout sauf mme emmanuel macron
d'une certaine façon et reprendre
quelques grands poncifs alors le
gaullisme évidemment même si beaucoup ne
savent plus ce que ça veut dire
bien le néolibéralisme du le libéralisme
la social démocratie à la thatcher ou à
la merkel on a vu ce que disait valérie
pécresse et xavier bertrand qui
également se met dans la suite des
malades macron d'une certaine façon en
remettant le local au coeur au coeur du
débat mais rien de neuf finalement sous
ce clocher la de la primaire alors avant
d'aborder le cas de la gauche pour finir
sur sur la droite frédéric sa cave il a
raison alors en vue de créer quand il
dit aujourd'hui personne n'a la
légitimité de s'imposer comme un sarkozy
ou comme un de gaulle bon xavier
bertrand tient la corde quand même dans
les sondages il a brillamment réussi
c'est ces élections locales il n'a pas
cette légitimité clairement
alors non il n'a pas le brillamment
réussi on pourrait on pourrait y revenir
en l'a longuement fait pendant les
régionales à il il est élu avec la
moitié des voix de de la fois tellement
en 2015 donc en réalité il est élu avec
un million quatre de vous en 2015 avec
700 milles seulement en en 2021 en 2020
donc il ya en réalité un affaiblissement
mais comme il ya une abstention énorme
on a l'impression que les secours
progressent mais mais mais ce n'est pas
le cas en réalité l abstention a fait
beaucoup de mal à tout le monde il a
joué avec une forte communication à ce
moment là il s'est placé tout seul dans
sa force en réalité c'est de générer
l'air c'est à dire de faire peur à l air
et de dire je vais y aller tout seul
malgré tout et j'ai le moyen de vous
faire très mal et comme l air n'est pas
en position de force eh bien elle sait
qu'elle n'a aucun candidat cette
formation politique qui puisse
supplanter écrasé xavier bertrand en
réalité le vrai travail que devrait
faire aujourd'hui les dirigeants de l
air c'est de faire une énorme campagne
de manière à légitimer le candidat qui
sortirait l ère de la primaire est de
contraindre xavier bertrand a à renoncer
mais pour ça il faut un vrai courage
politique qui n'en n'ont pas un dernier
mot quand même au niveau des proximité
idéologique il ya quand même de très
très forte proximité entre les l'air qui
ont rejoint emmanuel macron et ceux qui
ont quitté l air et qu'ils disent qu'ils
sont ni macro ni hier donc là on a quand
même aussi un espèce de brouillage des
cartes absolument incroyable on se
demande presque même comment ça se fait
que xavier bertrand n'a pas rejoint
emmanuel macron plutôt parce que la
compatibilité entre ce gaulliste social
est une social libéral emmanuel macron
est quasiment totale alors à gauche un
présent ça ça coince également on se met
pas trop d'accord sur l'organisation de
la primaire est-ce qu'on est dans le
même cas de figure que chez les
républicains elle et on l'appelle aussi
inscrite dans les statuts du parti
socialiste
clairement alexis poulain les délits
gens peuvent en faire l'impasse là
encore oui parce que déjà à gauche c'est
pas les candidats qui manquent mais
candidats déclarés il y en a peu encore
une fois
encore une fois il ya un jeu qui se fait
avec la france insoumise jean luc
mélenchon qui lui a décidé de toute
façon de faire une campagne solo en
disant ça ne sert à rien de rentrer dans
un jeu des primaires vous avez une autre
plateforme qui est la primaire populaire
qui aimeraient voir émerger une
candidature comme celle de christiane
taubira par exemple et anne hidalgo qui
se dit est ce que j'ai besoin finalement
du parti socialiste où est ce que ça
pourrait être délicat avec tous ces
couteaux convainc planté dans le dos si
jamais je sors trop tôt du bois donc on
exactement dans le même principe pire
encore je crois que chez l heure où on
peut remettre en scène la primaire on a
vu laurent wauquiez qui lui il décide de
ne pas être candidat qui va peser
autrement sur la campagne on a vu des
ralliements aussi qu'ils commencent à se
faire à gauche on a l'impression que
c'est encore plus brouillon et que par
contre c'est cette primaire où benoît
hamon était sorti vainqueur a été une
vraie catastrophe parce qu'on avait les
frondeurs d'un côté françois hollande
qui ne se présentait pas emon macron qui
a gagné en refusant de faire la primaire
à gauche alors qu'il venait du parti
socialiste est bien sûr l'attitude de
certains comme manuel valls qui ont
travaillé dès dès les résultats connus
donc je crois que c'est pareil à gauche
la primaire elle est vue avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude de lassitude et se dire
c'est pas forcément le meilleur outil
pour avoir un candidat très délicat
sinclair le mot de la fin est ce que
c'est démocratique tous est ce qu'il ya
vraiment une opposition en ordre de
marche pour reprendre certains termes
pour affronter
emmanuel mettront lors de la prochaine
présidentielle selon vous une opposition
à gauche une opposition tout court parce
qu'on sait pas bien si elle est de
gauche ou droite un puisqu'on se fait
parfois pas bien signé mais ne
manquerait de gauche ou droite selon les
observateurs il est il est vrai que
aujourd'hui oui
le
caractère ambigu de cette élection
présidentielle qui s'annonce c'est que
emmanuel macron est un président qui
n'est qui n'est globalement pas apprécié
même si dans les sondages il a un peu
plus haut que ses prédécesseurs
la défiance reste grande mais par contre
la fracturation de l'échiquier politique
est tel que on ne parvient pas ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre à fabriquer de
l'unité et donc à laisser espérer aux
français qui puisse y avoir une
alternance et là il ya un risque parce
que vous parliez démocratie le risque
est là à partir du moment où il ya plus
d'alternance possible ou simplement
c'est quelqu'un qui est minoritaire dans
l'opinion mais majoritaires dans les
urnes qui reprend le pouvoir d'une fois
sur l'autre et un moment si la
démocratie n'est pas capable de respirer
d'offrir l'alternance et bien c'est dans
la rue qu'on va aller chercher la
contestation et puis ça peut fabriquer
pour le prochain quinquennat et bien des
mouvements type gilet jaune plus plus où
l'insurrection ne s'arrêtera pas à la
porte de luz ouais merci frédéric cinq
heures pour cette analyse merci
également à vous alexis poulain